let's take away all the [ __ ] he's a
product
right when you're talking about business
right yeah entertainment business you
have a product if i got this phone right
mm-hmm and this is the 69 phone right
and i know that i have distribution
reach
in 12 countries
because of my prior relationships
i can box this phone up
mail it out to each country my liaison
and say hey
can you guys do something with this
phone
they're gonna say well whack
we heard a few things about this phone
but are we dealing with you directly and
i'm gonna say yeah you're dealing with
me directly
you won't have to deal
with the guy on the phone right and they
say okay whack based upon me our
relationship yeah we could distribute
five million phones a year for you
right
okay my attorney will be in touch with
you
at that point in time is it be a
contract a letter of direction
and a signature
so you know what i'm saying essentially
essentially what you're doing is
contracting your your services to six
nine no what i'm doing is
um like like you're setting up please
you're making sure you guys listen he
has a
he has a value to himself right right
and i have resources for the things
that's valuable
about this young kid right so simply
what i'm doing is i'm just bringing them
together bringing them together and
you're getting your cut
that's it obviously oh definitely yeah
that's business